[Music]
wow that's a tough fact to follow
all right if you're hosting any holiday
gatherings this year listen up okay eric
palacios and eric palacios of associates
um and associates excuse me the sponsors
of this segment have some important
reminders for you as you welcome people
back into your home take a look
eric welcome back
thanks for having me how are you good
good now we're talking holidays you know
usually a happy time but when you do
have people at your homes for small
gatherings injuries can occur now when
this happens or if this does happen in
your home is the homeowner responsible
for those injuries
that's a great question generally the
answer is the homeowner is not
responsible unless there's negligence on
his part uh so let's say that there's
something wrong with your property uh
there's broken tiles ripped carpet uh
something that is not up to code and
your guest is injured because of that uh
item that's not in a good condition in
your property then you would be
negligent and your guests would have a
cause of action against you
okay that makes sense now what if there
was no negligence but someone does get
injured what happens then another great
question and we see this a lot where
someone comes over maybe they're helping
you cook dinner they cut their finger
with a knife they burn themselves on the
stove or maybe they're going up or down
the stairs wearing flip-flops or high
heels and they trip and fall there was
nothing wrong with the house there's no
negligence on your part they were just
injured
in your property
normally homeowners insurance covers
this
under a medical payment provision so
even though it's not your fault even
though it might have not even been the
fault of the person that got injured or
just an accident
your insurance will cover it that way
your friend your family member doesn't
have to sue you doesn't have to uh ask
you to pay for their medical bills even
though there's no negligence a certain
part of their medical bills will be
covered
okay good to know now another time when
there's a lot of people going in and out
of your home is when you're getting you
know construction done so if you have
workers or construction workers in your
home right now and they get injured are
you are you responsible for that as the
homeowner
well that's another worry that
homeowners have if i have someone come
to do work on my house and they're
injured will i be responsible generally
the answer is no most companies have or
by law should have workers comp
insurance so if one of their employees
is injured while on the job
their own insurance takes care of this
even if the person does not have
workers comp insurance if it's just a
handyman or someone coming into your
house because they are there for
business for work for profit generally
the homeowner is not responsible for
their injuries
all right this is all so good to know
great reminders coming into the holidays
as we have people coming in and out of
our homes so thank you so much eric we
appreciate you
you're welcome thanks for having me
thank you to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring this segment
for more information give them a call at
at
702-444-7777
we'll be right back
[Music]